Before we talk about how to move on
to high fidelity prototypes, and
bring new people in on the creation
process, I want to step back for
a moment and
talk about what you can now do.
You've learned the fundamentals
of an iterative process for
making a better prototype.
By repeating this cycle, you will arrive
at a great prototype for a great app.
And you'll accrue feedback,
both positive and negative.
Also, remember from the product design
course, you may use your design sprint
skills to create new features or
parts of your product.
We've only gone along with you for
two iterations of this process, and
it's important to give yourself
room to iterate, learn and grow.
Many great apps went through 5, 10,
15 cycles of this process
before being built.
These cycles of prototyping
allow you to fail quickly and
get those bad designs out of the way.
Remember that every time
you go through cycle,
there are a few steps
you need to follow.
Define what information
you are looking to find.
Modify your current prototype to match
whatever feedback you've already gotten.
Put your prototype in front
of three to five users.
Collect their feedback.
And then analyze the feedback to see
whether you got the right information.
As you get better at this process,
you'll benefit from learning more tools
in order to build the right prototype
for the right step in the process.
We'll spend the next few videos
talking about those tools.